-I'm so happy to see you!
-Oh, it's great to see you!
-What did you bring with you?
-Okay, this is -- first of all,
I thought you'd appreciate it.
It's wrapped in
a Burger Heaven bag.
-Oh, dude, I remember Hamburger
Heaven.
-Yeah. Oh, my God.
It was so good.
-We used to eat there
all the time.
-So when I first came to "SNL"
in 2002,
this book had just come out,
"Live from New York."
And I decided -- they gave
all of us on the cast --
I'm sure you got one, too.
It's an awesome book that's,
like, very good
bathroom reading.
Good reading anywhere, but...
[ Laughter ]
I find it works in the bathroom.
-Yeah, it's a great book.
-So, what I decided to do is
to get each host every week
who came through
to sign the book,
so by the end of eight years, I
just had this amazing collection
of signatures, and I brought it
back with me so I could
I get the current cast to sign
it while I'm here this week.
-Wow!
-It's crazy, though.
It's, like, got -- There are
two presidents in here.
And U2 is in here and, like,
I'm sure you're in here.
I got a -- I actually wrote --
Because a lot of people,
I couldn't figure out who it is.
So this is my little graph of
who is who, so let me see --
Oh, I don't have my glasses.
-I can read it for you.
-Let's see, there's Bono
right there.
Barack Obama.
-What?!
[ Audience ohs ]
-Yeah.
-This is a great book.
-It's just amazing.
And this is --
you know, it's
so funny because I --
-Paul Rudd.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, you know -- Tom Brady
and Robert De Niro,
just -- Bootsy Collins.
It's just this amazing
collection of people from --
just a bunch of different
people, so it's just --
-Hanks!
-One of my prized collections.
And then Jason Sudeikis
got this for me.
We did this sketch called
"Potato Chip" at "SNL,"
and this was -- he had
a playbill made up of it.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that Blake Lively?
Who's in "Potato Chip" with you?
-Yeah.
Blake Lively and Sudeikis
is back there, so --
-I love that he made it
into a playbill.
-Oh, yeah. It was fun.
-Thank you for bringing this in.
I appreciate this stuff.
I will say one of the coolest
things that --
I really want to say,
I've experienced backstage,
you showed me first thing I did
when I walked in,
you showed me a picture
of your baby.
You have a newborn baby.
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have a beautiful baby girl.
-Little Zoe. Thank you.
-Will, I mean, that's amazing.
-Yeah.
The NFTs was just a thing
we said in the sketch.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just a thing in a sketch.
-They are FTs.
[ Laughter ]
They are FTs,
but I think it's a cool move,
because we've known each other
for a long, long time now.
But isn't it fun to go in -- I
go, "How are you doing, buddy?"
And we hug, and you're like,
"I got to show you my baby."
-It's the best thing ever.
And, like, you know, it's -- I'm
so excited to be here hosting.
But it's stressful.
You're running around
all over the place,
and I'm an overthinker anyway,
so I'm stressed out
about everything,
and then you go home and you're
with that little baby
and it's just -- you know, it's
like everything just goes --
-Yeah. Congrats on that.
-Calms you down.
-Congrats on your wife,
being married.
Also, you were telling me that
your family had to recently,
like, move stuff out of your --
you had to move
out of your house.
-Yes. Yes, so, this requires
a teeny bit of backstory
before I tell you what happened
with that.
So, back when I was working at
"The Last Man on Earth,"
Kristen Schaal,
who was my co-worker,
went on an alternative talk show
to yours --
you're not the only person
with a talk show.
[ Laughter ]
And she had gone --
Okay, I'll say it. It's Conan.
Conan.
She went on Conan's talk show.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-She ta-- One of the things she
brought up was the fact that
we worked two blocks away
from the biggest dildo
manufacturer in the country.
I think it's in the country
or maybe the world.
It's called Pipedreams.
[ Laughter ]
So Pipedreams sees this segment
and they go like, "Oh, my God.
That's amazing.
Thanks for bringing it up."
Sends invitations to us
to come and check out
their dildo manufacturing
operation.
All our "Last Man on Earth"
people.
So, like, an HR nightmare.
We all go over there --
-You said yes?
-Oh, yeah. Oh, my God.
How do you say no to that?
[ Laughter ]
-It's an HR nightmare.
-We all went over there,
and then sorry again,
but then I went on "Conan"
and told the story of the tour
that we took of the place.
And then they saw that
and they were like,
"Oh, we got to send these guys
tons of dildos
and different sex toys."
So, like, you know, of course,
another HR nightmare.
All this stuff is sent to us.
So, there were dildos around
our workplace for a long time.
And so I -- You know,
I'm not a dildo person.
[ Laughter ]
And I got rid of all my things,
but there was one thing
that I had to keep
because it was very --
I found it cute.
It's this, like,
miniature water cooler,
but instead of water,
it's sexual lubricant in there.
[ Laughter ]
So anyway, that's it,
and it's cute, right?
It's a cute, little --
[ Laughter ]
And it's like this big
and I'm like --
So that's the setup for this.
So cut to seven years later
or whatever it is,
and the Forte family is going
through a mold problem.
-Mold in your house.
-Toxic black mold.
-Wow.
-We had to get out.
So people come in and they,
you know --
Because we had a baby, so it was
like immediately get out.
Let's not take anything.
Just get out.
-Sure.
-So this company comes in.
I'll say it. Servpro.
They did a great job.
They come in and they, you know,
clean up all the mold
and they clean every individual
item that you have
and then box it up,
and so they got through with
that whole situation.
Mold's gone.
We go back into the place
and I got to go through
all the boxes.
So I'm looking through
all these boxes,
and, you know,
they're very good.
They label everything on
the sides of the boxes.
And it's, you know,
books and files.
It's a bunch of normal stuff.
And then I come to this one box.
It was a little confusing
because I couldn't
figure it out.
And yeah, so this was, um...
It was "personal moisture."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like -- I couldn't
figure it out,
because I didn't -- you know.
So I get it, I open it --
-Personal moisture.
-The lube cooler.
-Yes, the lube cooler,
which is not the name --
It should be the name of it.
-And then I realized --
I started going through
more boxes.
And there were like -- from
their -- how they labeled stuff,
I realized, "I think they think
I'm a creep."
[ Laughter ]
Or a weirdo. I don't know.
-I don't know if we can zoom
in -- if we can see what --
-Oh, that says "Sony video
camera, poop, fart."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "What is that?"
There's like an emoji --
I had a poop emoji candle
that somebody gave me, and then
a bottle of fart spray,
which is hard to describe.
It's just fart in a can.
-Yeah, fart in -- Yeah, yeah.
It's funny. It's a joke, yeah.
But this one made me laugh.
This one says...
-"Glass light bulbs, U-Verse,
pee container."
[ Laughter ]
I did know what that one was.
Container for your --
a medical --
My wife had gotten me for that.
That's a long story to that.
You don't need to know it.
But she did -- I am the owner of
a pee container.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you remember you got me
a gift once, a nice --
to pass the time?
Do you remember
that you got me this?
-I don't.
-You got me a puzzle.
And if I put the puzzle
together, it was your butt.
-Oh, yes!
[ Laughter ]
A friend gave that to me
as a gift
and then I regifted it to him,
because I was like --
[ Laughter ]
-But then you told me --
after you gave it to me,
like I was ever going to put it
together, you said to me that
it might be missing a piece.
[ Laughter ]
So I have to put it together
to see which piece is missing
and then call you.
But I still have the puzzle
somewhere.
-You got to do that!
-I know, I know, I know.
-We'll do it together.
-Let's do it together, perfect.
-Next time we're locked in
a freezer.
-We're locked in a freezer.
I want to talk about
"MacGruber."
the "MacGruber" series
on Peacock after the break.
More with Will Forte, everybody.